[Music]
hey y'all
um i'm jd long and i thought i'd pick up
our lecture from where we left it off
last year
at my session i actually it was a little
bit uncomfortable because i thought i
was going to come in here and totally
troll the crap out of you guys
and because i'm going to talk about you
know excel and spreadsheets and
like i got nothing left so i just made
up another presentation in the last five
seconds of the keynote
so uh let's just kind of go together and
see where this goes
now i'm i'm vice president of
uh risk analytics at a global
reinsurance company and don't worry
nobody else knows what that means either
and it was very confusing for my
daughter when she was growing up
so you know i'd go to parent-teacher
conference and things you gotta explain
like oh well what do you do
and so i just had shirts printed up
because it made
kind of everything easier to explain
so i'm very empathetic to the role of
spreadsheets my whole life
has been around spreadsheets and
programming
um i've got to give a quick disclaimer
i'm going to mention that i work at
renaissancery and i usually never
mention it because the stock trades down
every time i'm associated with the
company
i'm not giving financial advice and i'm
not giving forward-looking statements
my junk is on github though feel free to
get this presentation anything that went
into it will be there um
so this was my great trolling comment i
was going to lead with that i thought
was going to be
um provocative but kind of seems lame in
comparison to what we just sat there so
to migrate excel analysts to coding help
them be better at excel
first this is kind of what i'm going to
progress
with today and you know if you fail to
migrate them to r
or anything else at least you'll have
better excel and
that's not nothing so i'm coming from an
environment of
a workplace that's largely based around
excel now i am suspicious
the business analyst uh work environment
is not that different than analyst and
non-profit
or people who work in maybe finance or
other places
other types of organizations so i'm
going to speak kind of my first person
experience which is around business but
i think a lot of this is applicable
um some of you all may know me i run my
mouth on twitter way too much
um been involved in the art community
there for years
paul teeter a friend of mine he and i
are working on a second edition of this
book
for o'reilly we're in final editing
coming
soon to find book sellers near you and
no presentation
at this conference would be complete
without an allison horst
diagram now unlike everyone else who is
lifting
things that allison put on twitter this
was a custom
piece alison and i discussed what i was
presenting and she came up with this and
i think it's fantastic
so corporations tend to be sad silos
we've got
our business user clippy and excel and
word and they all go to the same parties
together
and we got we've got you know github is
over here with the codery type people
jupiter's a little concerned because
he's been reading all the crap on
twitter about how notebooks might not be
a good idea
and he's a little nervous and our man
has beautiful plots but is
all alone over in the corner
and i am here to tell you it doesn't
have to be this way so
we can have a totally different involve
a different relationship with these
tools
but it's not going to be the default and
i am convinced the reason we end up
with everybody in their own little silos
is
largely we're tribal animals
right we look and we say oh i am a
coder therefore i value
using these tools this certain way and
the way you're using the tool
looks illegitimate to me because you
don't have unit test and you don't have
this
and you don't always use version control
the way i would use version control
and therefore i'm more legitimate than
you and yes totally what we just
listened to
earlier today um
i think we need to broaden our tent a
little bit
and this is very much the theme we just
heard in the keynote
that we're using some similar tools
we between programmers analysts business
analysts
who use excel only we're using some
different tools
but there's some overlap and i'm not
going to be using
python or r any of the coding tools in
quite the same way that the professional
developers
who i work with use but i'm still using
them
and it's still production and
what's important for us to think about
is nobody wants to learn
coding all we want to do is we want to
kick ass
and if you go in to helping other people
learn a new tool and your mindset is
i am going to use a pedagogical method
to
profoundly change the way they think
nobody cares
like nobody cares they want to be a
superhero
and it's important to think about how do
analysts
think of themselves they're
they're solving problems they're doing
heavy lifting
and they're doing it all while it's on
fire and they are not going to take the
time
to necessarily learn a completely new
philosophy
about how to think about the world
because they're too busy
fighting fires and wanting to kick ass
so if you approach
helping people get better at what
they're doing
we need to think about how we help them
because we often
don't exactly help them get there in a
way that's meaningful to where they are
now who in here has heard of kathy
sierra anybody
because i'm totally ripping off like the
rest of my presentation is like kathy
sierra rebranded
she was a developer advocate before
developer ad advocacy was even a thing
she was wrote a number of books on java
comes from a java background but the
all the way down to the phrase kicking
ass comes from kathy sierra here and i'm
just re-circulating it for
our use case but she has this wonderful
graph about
learning and there's this suck threshold
and what we're trying to get to is the
passion threshold
so what gets people feeling passionate
about any tool is they feel like they're
kicking ass with it
and the suck threshold is when it is
horrible
nothing makes sense and we can't figure
out what to do next
and if we start trying to teach
especially to
this firefighter who's dead lifting
flaming weights and is worrying about
the whole company coming down
and if we spend trying to teach them
here's you know
five different types of objects you may
encounter
you're just moving along the time axis
and you aren't moving them up the
ability axis
so i would like to my kind of key
takeaway here is as you're trying to
talk to people in your organization
about upping their skill whatever the
skill is
get them doing things they perceive as
useful
more way more important than learning a
body of knowledge
now back to my whole okay help
people migrate excel by by helping them
be better at excel
let me give some specific examples
because that's a bit oblique
this is this is excel in mac with the
dark theme
because i'm cool very hip
tell my 11 year old um okay so we've got
this workbook called iris workbook
because we gotta
use iris right even though it's excel
i'm blending cultures here
um we've got this iris workbook
and i've i've introduced a sheet called
irish sheet
and it has a table in it a name table
called irish table
now the concept here that i think is
very important for
users of excel to begin to use is this
idea of a named
table um is everyone who in here is
familiar with this idea of naming a
table in excel
okay cool so a big chunk of people i
have noticed this is used very
inconsistently
and sometimes analysts who are
experienced with excel don't even know
this exists
and it's important to help them
understand the value of this because you
can do
really neat things like reference
columns in a function
that feels a little bit like you know
using a programming language right so
this is
you know my other provocative idea
that's no longer provocative that's
we're learning programming in a reactive
functional environment
and that's good this isn't a problem
this is a good thing
and we're helping an analyst or a
traditional excel user begin to think
about a data frame
and named columns in it and doing
operations on those
and this is a vectorized operation and
it's super
they can then use these things other
places like use that table
name when they make a pivot table this
is a natural segue
into things we do in our
one of the other things that's very
tempting to do when you know the tools
that we all know
is to say oh oh i'm going to take your
workflow and i'm gonna help you fix it
right and i'm gonna help you uh you know
we're gonna just do it all over and r
the philosophy that i have adopted after
failing miserably at that
and basically being told to go sawed off
is
help people take the hard parts the high
friction
parts and build some automation around
that
don't feel like we have to change
someone's life completely make an
incremental change
we've started in my team calling this
the 10 percent better
approach rather than trying to
completely fix a workflow
every time we do it we try to make it 10
better we have made
more progress through the 10 improvement
approach
than we have through any number of
projects that were grandiose
and ultimately failed because the scope
was too big
but i can make anything i do 10 better
you know but that our environment though
so
one of the challenges for new r users
is setting up the environment so where i
work we've taken it out of the system
we use jupyter lab anyway so we have a
jupiter lab log in
logs someone in gives them the r kernel
right that's pretty familiar
and it authenticates the user mounts
their drive space
loads their scripts you know but we got
an extra menu option in ours
because we just launched our studio from
here you're authenticated um
and a user can like play with r
without having to put a request into it
without having to
work out those database connections you
know it's just there
and the ability for low friction
play is important now i agree
it's not enough to just like have it
there and expect users to gravitate and
start doing things with it
but if they don't have to ask permission
like they don't have to get a service
test
a service desk ticket in order to get a
piece of software installed
the probability of them playing
experimenting doing something goes way
up
and especially if you've already got
database connections defined or file
paths or whatever makes sense in your
organization
now excel can be a bit of the
vice grip locking plier tool right
it's a fantastic tool does all kinds of
things
make dashboards with it it's fantastic
we can put a user interface on top of it
it's fantastic and we use excel
right in a lot of the same ways but this
is the
assembly line obviously right so this is
a professional production environment
i can't tell from the picture but i
guarantee there's 25
pairs of vice grip locking pliers
in this assembly floor right the
principle is
the tools it isn't oh a professional
production tool versus not a
professional production tool
vice grip pliers are used in production
right they just aren't
holding the doors on with them right
they're being used for very specific
purposes
let's give an example of a workflow that
i have found helpful
in illustrating pulling data in and out
of excel right because remember the
objective is not get someone out of
excel
it's how do we make their workflow
easier well a common piece
is do an etl process in our plop the
data
in an excel spreadsheet where you're
refreshing existing data
right and a lot of the tools kind of
assume you're exporting to excel
from nothing but i have a world where
analysts have built lots of goods
something
inside their excel so hey let's load um
open xls
xlsx and let's drop in our
our iris data we can do that with the
right table
uh function and the thing i would like
to point out is the two
lower parameters table style and table
name this is where we get
named tables in excel by using this
feature so
if they have built in their spreadsheet
formulas already
referencing tables and columns as i have
been trying to encourage them to do
we can replace their data now best
practice i don't illustrate it here
delete the first table out and then drop
the new in
because otherwise if you drop fewer rows
in then we're underneath it you got bad
data peeking out the bottom
not good so delete the first out and
that's not shown in this workflow but
then write it in
give it a name table and it is in their
environment where they're used to
working with it and we have just made
their process hopefully at least
10 less painful right this is the entry
drug
right the first hits free
um i think right now mike smith is
giving a presentation showing this exact
same
xkcd right so this is getting some legs
here
we had a logical fallacy uh in my team
for for a long
time at least i perceive it as a logical
fallacy we looked at this and this is
the whole you know if it takes
if it takes a long time to do to do to
um
automate a task but it doesn't save you
a lot of time don't do it
kind of seems obvious well this
illustration like so many things
is a model like that's a model of
reality that isn't actually reality
and it's wrong because all models are
wrong by definition they're actually
fairly useful to the extent the
assumptions hold
let me tell you a few of the assumptions
that are wrong with this image right
so one of the assumption is all time is
of equal value
so we can't take you know five hours to
fix this
uh because it doesn't save us that much
time it doesn't save us five hours over
the course of some
time period the fallacy there in my
world is
unequal time value so right around the
end of the quarter
we have a flurry of reporting activity
and that time is incredibly
precious august however
nobody's there who cares what we do in
august right so we can take time in
august
and if we can save a few minutes or a
few hours
during our very very busy period that's
a great return
and it's because our time isn't of equal
value
um the other thing is the current
frequency of reporting is is what we
would want to do in the future
and we have found this not to be the
case at all as we have automated things
we discover we run them more often and
we want to run them more often
we want to get the the analysis that we
thought we only needed once a quarter
oh if we can get that daily well that
might change how we do things
so it ends up not being stationary
[Music]
all time spent doing analytics is of
equal utility
some tasks are so awful
and tedious that your analysts will quit
and go work to facebook instead of doing
them right
don't make your analysts run away help
them automate those manual processes
not because they take a long time but
because they suck their joy
and the other assumption that's
fallacious is that automated and manual
workflows produce the same product
um this is not the case the product
produced
out of a automated process
should be more accurate if you're doing
it right
and if it's not it's at least inaccurate
at scale which is fantastic
the idea of our 10 percent better
approach
came from dan harris's book 10 happier
about
meditation and
we used to call it actually our
incremental improvement process but then
we had a different project called
incremental and we can't have a naming
clash and naming things is hard
so anyway we ended up calling this
process 10
happier and we have found that it is
truly sorry 10
improvement we have found that it has
made us 10 happier
and we're more time in this dynamic
environment
where our tools are getting along and
the people aren't in silos
and this is obviously not where we live
every day
but it's the state that we're aspiring
to be in more
so with that i'll wrap up i want to
point out the art here is by
the wonderful allison horst shouted her
on twitter
she's fantastic and wonderful and did
these uh we dialogued only online
and she came up with this wonderful
artwork so i gotta thank her now
i've got a minute for some questions
let's see we got mike's
oh go for it
so i had this custom made and it was i
realized as i was coming up here i'm
like oh you know i guess i should have
done like an etsy store or something
because i kind of think
that this may resonate this may be other
people's love language as well as mine
we got other questions
right back here
yeah that's a good idea uh the question
was do we do i have other tips or
resources
i'm i'm afraid that i don't and the ones
i do have are
super focused on the workflows that we
do
but i think this is a neat idea and if
someone would put together
like an online resource of this and i'll
give some thought to it i think that
would be that would be fantastic because
i'm sure there are design patterns
that get repeated over and over like my
example of popping data out and popping
it in
i'm suspicious that's a that's a common
design pattern
but sorry i don't have anything all
[Music]
right